observers have raised fears over the
future of democracy in Bangladesh
following widespread allegations the
country's national elections were
reached Prime Minister Sheikh Hasina's
ruling party won an unprecedented 98
percent of seats in Sunday's vote
Haseena has denied claims the vote was
fixed saying people came out in droves
to support her party opposition parties
have called for fresh elections the
country's Election Commission has
rejected those demands our correspondent
nimisha jaiswal is standing by for us in
the Bangladeshi capital Dakar
good morning to you Nimisha so how much
pressure is there on Sheikh Hasina and
her party how much pressure are there
under given the widespread allegations
of vert rigging well the question here
really Christine is who can exert this
pressure the international community is
what the opposition is calling on but
neighboring countries and their leaders
have already put out statements
congratulating Sheikh Hasina the main
regional cooperation organization of the
area the South Asia Association of
regional cooperation observers from the
half come out this morning and said the
election was free and fair the United
Nations put out a statement as well
saying asking urging Bangladeshis to
maintain peace but this does not mean
that they are rejecting the election the
pressure of course is all trying to be
built up by the opposition itself they
are have they have been in meetings
since the election happened and the
leader of the Opposition carmelo san has
also come out again urging bangladesh as
well as the international community to
reject this election to hold a
reelection under a caretaker government
and this is what he had to say I hope
that you know international community
will take note of this and since the
international community on the basis of
the United Nations Charter and the
United Nations decisions should not
recognize any government which does not
have the consent of the people
so that was bangladesh opposition leader
Kemal Hussain speaking to dwb Nimisha so
Bangladesh has a history of contested
elections but how angry are people
reports of illegals he's after this
latest election Christine the people are
definitely angry but more importantly
they are scared the waters the DW itself
spoke to who experience intimidation at
the polling booth one of them agreed to
speak to us anonymously on camera but
the other was not even willing to come
on camera anonymously because she was so
afraid for her safety now this of course
comes from months of intimidation that
observers have already stated that
Bangladeshis have been facing there has
been a crackdown on free speech the
digital Security Act that the government
passed earlier cracks down on
investigative journalism so of course
there is a climate over here where
locals feel like even when they're angry
they cannot express it because the
ruling party the Awami League led by
Sheikh Hasina is far too strong all
right Nimisha
what are the next steps for the
opposition here can they really mobilize
a government against the government as
Kamal Hussain is promising
well the crucial thing for the
opposition will be to start a People's
Movement a quick history lesson here
back in 1996 Sheikh Hasina herself was
an opposition and was able to pull off
demands for re-election exactly on terms
like this under a caretaker government
but she had a massive People's Movement
again with her supporting her and like I
mentioned if the people over here are
too scared to come out it would be very
difficult for the opposition to mobilize
a movement like this however at this
point we can just wait and watch if the
opposition weak as it is can cobble
together such a strong movement
all right that's VW's Nimisha guys well
reporting for us in dhaka bangladesh
thank you